what's up everybody
I want to start this podcast on a
serious note and there's something that
we probably neglected a little bit in
the last few years of us doing this
podcast but it's the believe all women
campaign and I feel like you know recent
events have transpired in Central Park
not the other Central Park thing but
this recent Central Park thing where a
woman you know called the police on a on
a black guy who was bird-watching just
asking her to lock up her dog or what is
it Lisa Lisa result
lock him up I got a crate I guess we
lock him up yeah so um but you know it
is true um we should I don't know if you
guys know this hashtag believe all women
but we've got to believe all women what
is she saying that the guy did I mean
harassing her god knows what like this
is cop worthy I gotta call the cops this
guy's attacking me she was he if she
says it we've got to believe it have to
because that it's incredibly it doesn't
matter if he wasn't doing anything he
was just bird watching I believe
everything I hear from the masses on
Twitter right is the quote belief some
women know it's believed all women and
first of all there's a white woman so
they're the most believable you believe
them the matter what right I mean they
they are psychic white women you believe
first Yeah right and then their other
rate you know other races you believe
them a little bit less obviously but if
a white woman a mask yielding white
woman oh he was masculine so believe
this is the most believable she's going
along with the guidelines right she's
weird am a she kiss me if she's calling
the cops on a black guy it must be for
something good must be when in history
has a white woman call the cops on a
black guy and it's been you know false
false never happened in history can't if
it did I honestly is there it one time
never not even a single time a single
what's your favorite cowboy what's his
name
trade no Michael I'm Emma Smith there's
something Emmitt I mean oh no I don't
know any there's probably nothing yeah
but uh
but all I'm trying to say is guys we
have to believe all women and it's
really it's really important and you
know and it starts with us I would say
you gotta believe your girl yeah I don't
believe Mike all the time you know
everything they say everything the
matter what they say she's right
I mean honestly yeah that's you can't
just ask a woman to leash her dog like
what is that yeah I mean that's crazy
that's astonished just violate it's like
that is rape culture bro honestly that
black guy was raping that white woman
bro yo you not know that black guy was a
way of raping that white with the way
that he he told her to leash her dog
yeah how is that different than rape I
don't see the difference you might have
been it might have been raped in a lot
of ways what did some black dudes call
women [ __ ] SERDES oh [ __ ] maybe he
burns whoopsie that's why he was
bird-watching oh but but it all
seriousness in all seriousness right
he's out here bird-watching do you think
he's just talking about her what are you
doing weirdo he's like Burt was he was
just watching her that is super
interesting okay I find it hard to
believe he was bird-watching in a park
okay yeah let's be honest he was
probably trying to rape someone but in
that situation I don't know if it was
her right I mean I think it was maybe
she cleans the GOP's because she knew he
was trying to rape somebody in the park
honestly who asked Alicia Dawg that's
just a movie
yeah that's the white women have like a
spider sense for a black male rapist
yeah especially essential part 100 dogs
like a white dude if she's if he's
saying leash your daughter's like Oh put
your mace away exactly because the dog
could run at him but if he's leased yeah
yeah I want you to be defenseless yeah
put your brass knuckles in your backpack
he's looking ahead that's what nobody's
doing nobody's looking ahead what is
that's the first step leash up your dog
tie it to a tree yeah use your sweater
talisha
there we go white women no man we gotta
trust white women believe all women bro
have to believe all this is women this
if there's one thing that we learned
from this weekend is believe
all women you know what we should have
learned it earlier say again we should
have learned it earlier you sure learned
it earlier he's just confirming what we
should have already known why are we
letting black people into the park guys
we know what could happen right we know
like they got there these white women
out there protecting the poor attempt in
the park like you don't need those park
rangers you need park officials you need
white women honestly get a little goofy
asshat why women should have all the
power why women should have all that
it's clear they know what to do it you
know what to do they don't abuse it how
many people got raped that day hmm not
her not her that's okay that just
stopped doing homeless one less negative
one rapes real talk
wait what what how did it come because
it would have been one if she didn't so
zero if she didn't do her civic okay one
minus one is zero not as negative how
you get negative rapes it didn't go in
her so that's zero I don't want to bases
that we got to believe all we've got
people with I apologize I'm like to
apologize they don't wanna look I said
some Chavan estate thing I've said some
tokenistic things bro I've said some
toven estate things on this podcast and
I really would like to say I apologize
to all women and from now on I'm gonna
believe you all no matter what you say
all the time no matter what you say I
believe you all the time that's it I
cheated on you in your dream yeah I did
that yeah I did that shouldn't be until
your [ __ ] dream yeah and your
stupid-ass subconscious that you can't
control
idiot I
why would you make me there your dream
is never less the best-case me here
their fantasy is just Vega to you I
believe over you know I believe no men I
think that I think believe all women is
not I don't think it's it's extreme
enough I think believe no men I think
that's the next next step what do you
think about that I think you're right
believe if you have to you know men you
can't stop it believe all women do you
understand no man because if you're
believing all women you can't believe
all men - yeah and maybe you're right
maybe just believe no men if you believe
no men no matter what women say it's
gonna be believed because you don't
believe the man exactly now what happens
when these dykes start raping each other
hmm
believe both now we talk believe both ow
you believe both what about a training
ah
which way male the female female to male
male a female nope
male the female male the female don't
believe female to male believe because
that woman is still all no real talk
honestly if a female [ __ ] turns into a
man and she says she's a man you know
what I do I believe her
you gotta believe God you gotta believe
all women now if a man turns its woman
do we believe him apparently not we
don't believe men can't believe man
can't believe men bro all he's doing is
trying to get away with lying in the
future that's why he's doing
Changez sex to a woman so you think oh I
should believe her
no he's just doing it to plot some [ __ ]
oh my god what a scumbag I never have
good and I never have neat or this is a
[ __ ] garbage how often you dream about
your girl cheating on you
never never right you're what a piece of
garbage you are the channel take your
insecurities into your [ __ ] dream
world I don't let her get good dick in
my dreams
that you would not let your girl that
you love that I love get so fat dick
dream time with the skinny baby
oh [ __ ] could you do that how could you
put her through that you know why please
tell me I don't know because I'm a man
and I am therefore garbage oh my god bro
I mean it's just I I'm so bad you know
we all are in this room honestly believe
nothing you heard on this podcast
believe nothing absolutely nothing I'm
disgusted by us all the only way it
would be a fact is if we had a woman
come sit in this chair and she validated
every single thing yeah that's the only
way it is so we'd like to apologize to
all women for not believin y'all now
this weekend really proved how important
it is to believe you you [ __ ] get it
you know I I'm sorry yeah and we're
sorry about that brutal rape that you
had to go through Oh God brutal brutal
could you put a leash on your dog
could you please leash up your dog so I
can watch the birds and not be scared
real talk
yeah I just I'm sorry we had to start
the podcast off on such a serious note
man usually we don't like to do it we
like to keep things light and we like to
keep things smooth over here but some
things are so serious you have to
address them
[Applause]